okay everybody here we are once again it
feels like it's only been hours because
it has but donald trump
is holding a press conference today at
the bottom of the hour i expect it to be
extraordinarily humiliating why because
that's the theme of everything donald
trump is doing here he is just earlier
today
trying to say yosemite and if this isn't
humiliating i don't know what is
when young americans experience the
breathtaking beauty of the grand canyon
when their eyes widen in amazement as
old faithful bursts into the sky
when they gaze upon yosemites yosemite's
towering sequoias who hasn't been
overwhelmed emotionally
by the towering sequoias of yosemite and
then of course the axios interview
absolutely and completely unhinged in
fact we had a clip published about the
axios interview
oh my god it published an hour ago and
it has a hundred and ten thousand views
already
i don't know we've ever had a video get
a hundred and ten thousand views in the
first hour holy [ __ ]
i'm now i'm shocked by what i'm seeing
right now
wow well in any case that's someone
right it's shocking trump even said
sequoia that's something to look at
uh maybe after this press briefing which
is just
um going to be one thing on top of
another now i should mention
um oh thanks to kathy padgett for the
youtube subscription
c asks via super chat what would you do
if you were a billionaire
i don't think about stuff like that i
just think about you know what am i
going to do tomorrow
in reality and neutral music says
plasma absolutely and evan fields says
counting down the days until the right
starts abandoning him after axios
slash today i don't know how widely that
interview is going to affect trump's
polling
but 30 million people had seen that
three minute clip where trump talks
about the death rate
that's a lot of people in the first 12
hours so that that's that's a real
problem
for uh for donald trump for sure so
here's another just really weird thing
donald trump tweeted
earlier today um where is it hold on a
second
here it is whether you call it vote by
mail or absentee voting
in florida the election system is safe
and secure tried and true
florida's voting system has been cleaned
up so in florida i encourage all to
request
a ballot and vote by mail how stupid is
this so first of all trump has been
insisting vote by mail is
fraud and absentee voting is fine
of course what we're talking about is
expanding absentee
after saying it's going to be so
rigged that we might have to delay the
election now he says everybody in
florida should vote by mail
it's completely incoherent and i'm
hoping that we get uh questions asked
about it today
um during the upcoming press briefing
scheduled for the bottom of the hour
it's it is completely incoherent it just
doesn't make any sense at all
now i do want to tell you guys about
something very very ugly that's going on
okay um shots were fired across the bow
today
from fellow progressive sam cedar and
um he made the extremely
ugly allegation that he believes the
recent
rise in subscribers on the david pakman
show youtube channel
may have been that i am using bots okay
this is very ugly and i see people in
the chat already
realizing that this is a uh
alliance of left media
where things could go very very bad okay
i don't like this at all
this was brought to my attention today
by any number of viewers
listen to what was said today i except
for
uh for specific people so i appreciate
that
yeah one other one other thing uh pacman
is out there
challenging you to a race to a million
first of all that's not true i've
challenged no one to anything
um you know he's really coming after you
and he's pulling away you guys were
basically tied around
90 908 908 000 uh
youtube subscribers he's already at uh
9 12. and some people on twitter were
saying
well yeah that's because pacman does
more videos but that's like saying
the person who runs the race faster
wins and that makes the race unfair i
mean
i don't know he just seems to be out
working you i smell bots
i smell bots that is a completely
baseless allegation bots we have built
up what is now a following of
912 896 subscribers
oh wow we're like a stone's throw from 9
13.
he's calling you a fake person
understand what that implies
if you're a subscriber to this channel
and sam cedar says our subscribers are
bots
you don't exist that is
i can imagine no bigger insult so that
is
nasty nasty nasty nasty so
look here here it is right now put this
video up look
folks ronald reagan has just informed me
that
david pakman has taken a lead in our
race to get to a million
subscribers and i
am making a personal appeal to you right
now
hit the subscribe button it's not
necessarily where i'm pointing to i
don't know where it is maybe it's
maybe it's down here or over there but
hit the subscribe button
don't let david packman steal our valor
that is a direct attack and i i'm
already subscribed to my channel so
i can't really do a damn thing about it
but
i know that you find people are not
going to allow these allegations
to be gotten away with and uh we we are
not going to be
taken down by false allegations
of bot usage now what i do want so
by the way if you're watching please hit
subscribe
because it's free and we could get to 9
13 wow
we all of a sudden just picked up 70
subscribers another 50 and we will roll
over to 913 000. so you can help
fight shots across the bow but i want to
mention something else
i have to be really careful with what i
say here i've been keeping this
pretty close to the vest and i'm i'm not
going to
i'm not going to make any specific
allegation today but
here's what i want you to think about um
socialblade is a website where you can
see people's subscriber growth or
reduction or whatever
there are channels where if you look at
subscriber growth
you see that it increases not in let me
i'll actually show you what it looks
like this is what like a normal
um this is what a normal chart would
look like
okay so subscribers where is it
um
oh where i don't even know where it is
hold on
oh i i can't even find it the point is
there's a page where you can look at new
subscribers per day
the normal thing would be a curve right
where like
most days you get zero or one thousand
because it's in thousands
zero or one thousand or most days you
get between one and three
there are some channels i'm not going to
tell you which you can if you think you
know who would be a grifter who would do
this on youtube
you go look for it i don't want to make
the allegation
there are people where if you look at
their subscribers it's essentially
zero and then you'll have 10 000 in one
day
and then a few weeks go by zero no gain
and then 10 000 in one day it's like a
step ladder of subscribers
that is not natural subscriber growth
that's all i'm going to say
i'm not going to tell you which channel
it is and i'm not going to tell you
why i think that it looks that way but
if you
want to spend some time clicking around
socialblade and thinking about
who might be a grifter in this space
that's where i'm going to leave it okay
unnatural subscribers
uh very very good thank you to i'm spoon
necklace and zach prakowski as well as
ragnarok
for subscribing over on twitch prime
um wow my viewers are actually
smarter than i holy [ __ ] i'm i'm
actually surprised at what's going on
right now
that's very very interesting what what
people are posting on both youtube
and uh and twitch that's very very
interesting
okay a couple of other super chats are
coming in
um where is this
zachary foster says david you pretty
pretty good news on treating severe
coveted patients with a drug called
eviptodill i have not read that yet
classy andy says is it bad that i skip
when trump is talking and listen to you
instead not at all it's good
danny thompson says the name of this
video should be hello darkness my old
friend i've come to talk with you again
thanks for sticking with all this junk
it's needed
evan fields says jealousy is a [ __ ] we
love you david
chakaseki says david could you please
ask your guest
fenton muhly to do a quick impression
for us long time fans i don't know who
that is
i don't know what uh what the joke is
marika says i don't like these
shakespearean developments with sam
cedar dark times it is
when i was uh when i was notified of
what happened today on the sam cedar
show
i was very distraught very very
distraught
proton jinx says sweden has the highest
educated populous in the world by
percentage of university educated
yet a full third are skeptic about
vaccines i'm
losing faith in humanity i don't know
that about um
sweden that's interesting thanks to
susan care or carray
for the soy boy subscription cg says i
would
take this as tongue-in-cheek and more
friendly banter than anything else i've
said worse about my best friend out of
no ill will
oh yeah the entire sam cedar thing i
just did is totally fake
sam and i text multiple times it's it
was all a joke i hope people understand
that that it's not it's not
serious uh jonathan says perhaps sam
doesn't realize that you understand
youtube's algorithm and digital
marketing better than he does
wow counter shots fired
cole fuhrer has signed up as a soy boy
alex isaacson says sam show is so slow i
used to listen but i couldn't stand the
long stretches of nothing you rock david
that's ugly
every show is different and every show
is valuable
um caicos umbra says powerful pack bots
dave lara has subscribed puddin pop says
i can't believe
david botman is trying to beat sam cedar
to 1 million what a joke sam cedar's
background is far superior to bot man's
copycat wall panels nasty nasty stuff
ceruse palmer says sam is so annoying
many pauses and um's get the words out
it's just a delivery tool i don't i
don't think it's bad
candido moreno says how is jesse lee
peterson off camera was he the same as
on camera yeah he was actually identical
um jessie lee's uh
acolytes maybe we would better call them
employees
they were they all seemed to be big fans
of the david pakman show a couple of
them wanted pictures with me
but jesse didn't seem to like it and he
was
uh very very much exactly the same
exactly the same
all right we are off and running on a
twitch hype train
thanks to tulmu who has subscribed with
twitch prime
we are standing by for donald trump at
the bottom of the hour kaylee mckennany
was
63 minutes late today and spoke for only
about 22 minutes
63 minutes late spoke for 22 minutes
bad very very bad we'll see what happens
with donald trump
uh very shortly a drumpf
twittler says david show us your
cucumber yeah i should do a
i should do a um a garden tour soon
my cucumber plants you can't even
imagine what's going on with my cucumber
plants it's
it's wild i my plan is
to pick them relatively early and pickle
them
because i've got a great pickling uh
recipe
brine i guess we would call it thanks to
our
guy mang rygai mang artistic simplicity
and
geode vent for supporting on twitch
pushing us into a level two hype train
renholder says i tried to send you a
message in binary for a bot joke but it
wouldn't let me oh well
why are republicans so obsessed with
telehealth when it's just a symptom of
the problem yeah it's it's completely
uh laughable now every day is all about
telehealth it's wacky let me say thank
you to
anders svensson wow who is new member
number one today
phillip blackwell is new member number
two
at joinpakman.com uh
wala is me says 160 thousand trump
virus deaths surpassed just now
officially
yeah let's look at that official
coronavirus numbers there it is ladies
and gentlemen
a tragic milestone truly a tragic
milestone
45 000 cases today earlier i was told
florida stopped testing they did they
stopped testing on
july 29th in advance of the hurricane
testing not expected to really resume
until tomorrow in many counties so you
can't
you literally can't believe these
numbers um
when you look at these case numbers wow
that looks great well they stopped
testing on july 29th and then the
numbers declined
however when you look at deaths 245
deaths today
a big spike back up to near record highs
so things are really bad
icu usage last i looked was 100
in florida which is you don't want to be
at 100
hauser slat
come on guys he didn't get me there um
where did that go
would you ever date a lady trumpist if
she was a total hard body come on guys
give me a break
also my girlfriend thinks you have
amazing eyebrows did you shape them no
not at all
uh these are just um you know in the
i think in the semitic lottery what i
got was the thick hair
and extremely well-shaped eyebrows and
in fact that's really it
so um no i don't have to do any work on
my eyebrows whatsoever
tristan coffey says you have inspired me
to make sure my loved ones truly
understand
just how important this election is you
rock excellent
it is extremely important and i'm glad
you're doing that
martin van gorp says in which european
country would you like to live there's
so i mean i don't know there's just so
many i mean paris is one of my favorite
cities
uh in the world i have family in spain i
have family
um well uh israel is not uh europe
but um there's so many so many great
places in europe that i've enjoyed
london is great in its own way um
italy has just such amazing places
sarang sheth says if trump's internal
polls show him leading
why does he think he will lose a mail in
election won't both parties be cheating
love from india
yeah i mean it's it's all an incoherent
narrative there's no question about it
saucy mcsaucer says sam's gonna win it's
obvious now the soy boys over at pacman
don't have uh endurance to reach 1
million
sad sam gang david botman
guys we're not going to let them get
away with that right we have just
reached 913 000 subscribers
and if just 700 more people subscribe we
will be at 9
14. there's 7 000 people watching on
youtube if
10 of you subscribe we get to 9
14 and we keep fighting the very ugly
allegations that came out of the
majority report with sam cedar today
which alleged that my subscribers on
youtube are bots
they are not they are real people people
like you
uh and i appreciate every one of you
michael corley
says i'm so tired of this blank every
day how exhausted are you
yeah it's tiring but you know i i the
full weekend and often it's a three-day
weekend i
disconnect from it all i think that
that's a good thing to do
health-wise catherine belfiore has
grabbed a soy boy level subscription
kenny redmond says
thanks for cutting off kaylee earlier
today that was unfortunate they were
spreading propaganda
very much so let's see what's happening
on twitch where people are
using our new bttv emotes which have
been enabled if there are
specific bt tv emotes you would like me
to enable
you can email me through the contact
form on my website and i will enable
more of them
we have two minutes left to complete a
level three hype train about a minute 45
now actually
and um then we would be on to level four
and level five eventually as as far as
uh as far as i know
thanks to bendley for subscribing with
prime
also wisdom cnd has subscribed with
prime
aka silent x has subscribed
aussiepriest has subscribed
and gqwk
just it's it's incoherent letters has
subscribed as well
pulling us closer and there it is
level four level four hype train
triggered
right away as we wait for donald trump
scheduled for two minutes ago
ko brian says i believe you david i'm
looking at social blade
now what happened between november 25 to
december 2 in 2019
you had a sudden spike of subscribers we
had we had some viral videos in that
area
uh i don't remember specifically what we
had
but we had a very very good week that
week
ceruse palmer says sir oh cyrus rhymes
with virus fyi okay sometimes
that name is ceruse and sometimes it's
cyrus apologies
cyrus kenny redmond says my insurance
has provided telehealth for years
many have kian zhang has subscribed at
the soyboy level
rajen savjani says besides just
desperately wanting power is the reason
trump wants to stay in power to avoid
prison
possible sealed indictments i actually
don't think so i mean it's totally
plausible like plasma but i actually
think it's just his narcissism he can't
lose he really can't um
thanks to defranco games gifting ten
subscriptions on twitch we are now
at a level five hype train we completed
one level hype uh five hype train
earlier today
we are now targeting a second
level five hype train as they continue
to i guess we've got a zoom and focus
test happening here
and we might get in really tight on this
guy yep there we go very very tight
and then now back out after the focus
has been adjusted
total pros these guys
excellent um
oh wow we've completed the level five
hype train we're actually close to 200
percent level 5 hype train that's insane
walter says what would you say the
traits are of a good debater such as
yourself i don't consider myself a good
debater but i think
some of the traits include not allowing
yourself to be distracted
into ancillary points and really keeping
the focus on
on what is being discussed uh ready
access
to rebuttals i think is important
both a macro you need a macro and micro
understanding of issues in order to be a
good debater
i wish i was a better debater i don't
consider myself a good debater
dominic richardson says can we start
calling trump's presidency the reign of
failure yeah of course
oof got gotham says jesse's staff was
fans of yours only one thing i can say
to that
amazing neptune says
common david don't forget about your
large cucumber
oh my god terminal 3 says trump
is speaking at the bottom of the hour i
don't know why i subject myself to this
other than i want to make sure he's
voted out soon
yeah fair greasy shell says i always
fail the recaptcha tests now i know why
casey martin says do you think trump
will try to pass a stimulus package via
executive order
or any other means in order to buy votes
great show
i would not put it past trump to try
anything
whether he will actually get away with
it is a different
question thanks to sinful siren games
and star
fury omega for the twitch prime
subscriptions i also want to say thanks
to aaron jacobson who's new member
number three today at joinedpakman.com
kim
mung is new member number four
donna lennon is new member number five
richard trottier or trottier is new
member number six today
thank you so much i appreciate that just
lost my earpiece i'm gonna have to
adjust this this little clip that goes
on my shirt
something about it seems to be i've had
it for like eight years so maybe it's
time for a new
new piece of equipment knife is
sharp is also subscribed with prime
delia ann wolfe has grabbed a soy boy
subscription
uveon says so if a vaccine
does happen to come out during the trump
presidency
how is he going to square that with all
his anti-vac supporters
it will never be mentioned it just is
not going to be mentioned
we're down to the last 45 seconds
of our hype train we are nearly at 300
percent level five as a reminder the
best we've ever done is 620
level five we're currently at 285 down
to just the last 30 seconds
a kinky turtle has subscribed with the
message
i'm a turtle okay
the new professor has subscribed with
prime
zeko guy has subscribed as well as the
feister
down to the last 10 seconds
um is completing a level 5 hype train
considered great on on twitch because i
think it's pretty good
i don't know if it's common like there's
probably streamers that complete it
every time i don't know but i i
kind of i'm flattered by it yes
people think yes maybe maybe not we
don't know
it means i'm virile okay that's an
interesting spelling
oh man twitch is uh twitch is an
interesting place
matthias germany oh we just lost
matthias where did that go
where is matthias germany there it is
matthias germany hey david today i
worked
great on the like button from the
standpoint of destroying
thank you for your wonderful work i
wonder i don't know if that's some kind
of google translate type of stuff that's
weird
big daddy yayan says you should be
careful while you and sam are racing to
one million
kyle kolinsky mate jump ahead out of
nowhere keep up the good work
certainly could happen i don't know
where kyle is from the standpoint of
subscriptions either
satu gustafson says i know i'm not a bot
i know it as well johnny minogue says i
bet we can find
tremendous plasma at yosemite everyone
says that
yeah let's just look at it one more time
because it's just like it's like a
it's it's a car crash i can't look away
actually let's look at the short one
when they gaze upon yosemites your
seminites
cowering i'm reading a book about some
mormon murders it's a great book by the
great
john krakauer and yosemite
seems to me like the name of one of
those fundamentalist latter-day saint
preachers i don't know why that's what's
uh coming to mind
tracy ulrich and eamon barrett have
subscribed
j.l switzerland says can't believe how
certain people in the u.s behave in
public
because they don't want to wear masks we
have been following what authorities
have asked us to do and we are well off
best from switzerland yes switzerland
love switzerland i've been to lugano
i've been to zurich i've been um
i guess that's it as far as uh
switzerland is concerned
tyrell falad says have you seen what's
going on in beirut yes
on the earlier stream we looked at just
the
the videos are so devastating that they
seem like movie special effects and then
you realize that they're not
still don't know death toll still don't
know um
what uh i haven't seen anyway
anymore said about cr responsibility
anybody taking claiming responsibility
or anything like that and
my plan is to read up between now and
tomorrow's show
let me say thanks to larry schmitz who's
new member number seven today at
joinpacman.com
also kathy kirsch is new member number
eight
tom oh i almost already did i think
thomas no thomas collier
is new member number nine today
uh who am i missing here aaron jacobson
is new member number ten
and i think that that does get me caught
up
um how late will they be today i don't
know
um scheduled for 10 minutes ago kaylee
was 63 minutes late today
let's just see if donald trump has
updated the scheduling
um
wait a second trump is being interviewed
at five
must be pre-recorded right otherwise
there's no way he could do this this is
weird
uh yeah that's odd anyway
all we can do is wait reporters starting
to trickle it's
it's it's so disorganized you're
absolutely right
i've never seen a white house this
disorganized it's bizarre thank you to
um pusher man scrubby bubbles
raziel kanos and r ragin
savjani as well as nato jenkins tv
luke l b and royal fino
who have all subscribed on twitch twitch
has been blowing up lately i don't know
what's happening on twitch i think me
being in that chess tournament is
helping
uh but twitch has been on fire fire fire
fire
um okay
all right you broadcast to millions and
wear a t-shirt
fail oh my god i wore a t-shirt can you
imagine
sam dean says g'day dave genuine
question what is the exact
role of a press secretary the exact role
is to be
a funnel through which the thoughts and
ideas of the president
are funneled to the press it's a conduit
essentially which is
why it's so funny when the press
secretary says i can't speak for the
president
it's like well that's your job that your
job is to be here as a conduit between
the president and the press
um how does how does kaylee magnani
compare to the actual job description uh
you know
it's that's uh that's a question for the
ages
sean adams says every time i try to
watch sam's show it seems like a gaggle
of school children giggling and he's
always yelling at people to pause it
wow jr says what will you give to your
millionth subscriber
so that's a fair question you know one
of the reasons that i don't know that
we're going to offer
a a gift to our millionth subscriber if
it ever happens
is that um there's no way to know
exactly who it is
because of how youtube works at this
point we just wouldn't know
so i i don't know that that's the way to
do it
austin show is here oh hey austin wow uh
i'm honored austin show is a
major major twitch streamer
with um wait is that the same austin
show is that austin is that like the
austin show from the austin show
um oh you're honored to be in my
presence okay austin and i actually do
dm
on uh on twitter every once in a while
great to see you here
uh this is it's 13 minutes ago austin so
that means we shouldn't have more than
like a few hours to wait
quirky quip says thoughts on media band
for goop conference
familysearch.org free genealogy site
passenger list
census may help you with your polish
grandfather i don't know
what you're talking about quirky quips
that's it seems like you're dish
galloping me
i know all about my polish grandfather i
knew him until i was
uh i think so how old was i 1617 when he
passed away
what the problem we're having is for me
to get my european union passport i need
my grandfather's birth certificate my
grandfather's birth certificate
was presumably burned up during world
war ii he escaped poland but he
was born in a part of poland that is now
belarus there's no diplomatic relations
between poland and belarus so it's like
i don't know how the hell to get this
birth certificate which i need
in order to get my european passport so
that's that's the complexity but from a
genealogy standpoint i'm good
karsten muller says that axiom interview
axios
was the best interview i've seen in a
long time listen
i've never seen anything like this
happen
on our youtube channel we published a
video
at 4 pm eastern about the trump axios
interview
that was an hour and 45 minutes ago it
has 175 000 views already
we have in all the time i've been doing
this i've never had a video get 175
000 views in an hour and 45 minutes
it's people are reacting
very very triggered by the trump axios
interview
of course it's bots i mean it's all fake
i mean what am i talking about but
that's if you're watching sam cedar by
the way if you are just joining us
major major shots have been fired today
uh
by sam cedar alleging that you fine
folks are merely bots take a listen to
this
it's hard to put your finger on it
exactly but there's like kind of a train
wet
train wreck the big oh
wow this is just crazy hold on a second
with a weird small face oh wait no it
was 148.
die except for uh for specific people
listen to this
this is ugly guys this is really really
one of the one other thing uh pacman
is out there challenging you to erase to
a million
untrue um you know he's really coming
after you
and he's pulling away you guys were
basically tied around 90 908 908 000
uh youtube subscribers he's already at
uh 9 12.
and some people on twitter were saying
well yeah that's because pacman does
more videos but that's like saying
the person who runs the race faster
wins and that makes the race unfair i
mean
i don't know he just seems to be out
working you i smell bots
i smell bots can you imagine can you
imagine that
i have been assailed by sam cedar and by
the way this caller
they were wrong we're not at 9 12. we're
at 913
000 and in fact we're only a couple
hundred from 914 thousand we've got 10
000 people watching on youtube right now
we could be at 920
000 by the end of the stream if people
put it together so i am going to be
issuing a statement tomorrow i'm working
right now with legal representation
i'm working with my agent i'm working
with a crisis counseling
uh center on a pr crisis pr
and we are we are strategizing we're
going to hit back i just want everybody
to know
if you think that i'm going to accept
this
and i'm just going to go and recede to
my backyard garden with my cukes and my
zooks
we are hitting back tomorrow so mark my
words
this is going to get very ugly if i have
anything to say about it
and just as a reminder this is all fake
we're just kidding
sam is my friend okay sam is my friend
thank you
alfred churchill says why doesn't a
reporter ask him
donald for real are you okay i think it
would
actually listen if a reporter actually
asked trump about his his cognitive
state
during one of these it would go insta
viral
it would be unbelievable and i would i
think it would be a very reasonable
question and i would love to see it
thanks to goth kitty t calculator ansel
out my window for the twitch prime
subscriptions i appreciate that
what else do we have going on reporters
are filing in
let me mention just very briefly we
uh now are regularly doing two or three
streams a day
in addition to the hour podcast and
broadcast show
the youtube clips and the bonus show
with total humility
i would suggest to you that if you would
like to support the work we do
in a really small way this is not big
big stuff i'm not asking for your
firstborn or your second born or
anything like that
grab a membership on my website
joinpakman.com my
pledge to you is it'll take you under a
minute if your computer skills are
average to above average it's very cheap
if you use that coupon code 2020 now
it's like a dollar
80 a month okay if you pay for the
entire year at a time
and i will thank you on stream because i
it's just so inspiring when people sign
up
chandler page for example is new member
number 11 today
uh phoebe wolf love the name phoebe
phoebe is number 12.
william brazoski or brazoski
is number 13. yat
as is number 14 an unusual name
anthony antos is new member number 15
today
stinky pete wow is number 16 today
and uh michael knute michael knute
is number 17 today no more no more
website crashes our website we've cut
quadrupled hosting resources on our
website so that when people go to sign
up um you uh it won't crash
and the website is completely bot
friendly that's a fair question on
twitch
in fact most of our members are bots
um using fake credit cards so yeah it's
it's very very much bot friendly
by all means okay other super chats are
continuing to pour in as
reporters enter the room let's see here
um i missed a bunch let me go back up
wow i did so many of these flew by i
don't want to miss anybody
okay here we go matt seim says do you
think joe will need to call on the
military to remove the don from the
white house
i don't think so nope i don't believe so
satu gustafsson
says please promise me you will vote
this orange nightmare out in november so
i can quit day drinking greetings from
germany i will do my part
juggalo trey says hey david big fan will
merrick garland ever get a justice seat
i don't believe so
jade smitheling sends a super chat
maestro cam have you heard the latest on
the possible trump pump and dump scheme
from eastman kodak
yes senator warren's having the sec
probe them that's good
let's see red clasher says hey david
thank you for pulling me out of the
alt-right rabbit hole i fell into at 14.
we really need critical thinking to be
taught in high school desperately
desperately mark anthony says yosemites
love you pack yeah that's uh that's a
reference to this
when they gaze upon your semites yes
semonites
what he meant was yosemite sequoias all
right the very very sad that that's the
president
tiamat says pac-man despite the
click-baity thumbnail
your clip on polling and how they're
relevant was spot-on good work
thank you chris branigan says do you
think there will be massive protests and
riots
per a trump re-election what's the worst
case in terms of public response
i think the worst case is if it's close
but biden wins and trump claims that
it's rigged
that is what scares me that you are
going to have the gun people
as i know them out on the street very
quickly
and um you know that's that's that's not
that's scary i want to say thanks to
gnome katz lachaim my friend i
appreciate that you are new member
number 18 today
hayden hagaboom is new member number 19
on my website
semvote is new member number 20.
sean dunphy is new member number 21.
genevieve barrons is new member number
22.
oh my god something weird just popped up
on my screen i think i just got hacked
bridget reese is new member number 23.
chris vind and josh mars are numbers
24 and 25. in that case let's go for 50.
also want to say thanks to
william havukanen
seems like a finnish last name you are
number 26
jonathan herman matthias seliger
chris lowe juan fonte
are new members 27 to 30. wow
and a user signing up under the name
donald trump whose real name is chris
has signed up as well and you are number
31.
very very big day very big day
um claude doust oh sorry um
matthew mcdonald says do you have any
thoughts on the fec not being in a
quorum
and the republican on it leaving when it
does i did not see that story i'm sorry
claudia doused says french quebecer
canada wants trump gone
yeah uh quebec montreal one of my
favorite places
hope to be up there soon who knows when
i'll be allowed
oz says top five presidents go i
i hate lists like that i feel like it
debases the discourse
robert summers says what's worse wearing
a t-shirt or wearing a tan suit
oh oh my god wearing a black t-shirt
during a stream is much
less offensive than wearing a tan suit
if i wore a tan suit fox news would be
calling for my resignation eric
wallquist says what my favorite part of
the axios interview is it shows 45
doesn't get math if we have the most
confirmed cases
it tracks that we have lower deaths per
case yeah it's
that the math the math portions of the
axios interview
are historically embarrassing
historically embarrassing
uh very much appreciate beauty and the
game
signing up with twitch prime creel 513
your lord few skills has sign up
signed up with the message do you
believe the current case and death
numbers
i addressed that at the top of the
stream so i don't want to redo it for
people who have been here but feel free
to kind of
scroll back for that um
thanks to vilgoopel extra high goth
kitty for the subscription
and uh i think that uh
oh grandmaster benjamin feingold has
subscribed lachaim i appreciate that
um i watch uh benjamin feingold
regularly uh yes
thank you great to see you ben
people furious that ben subscribed okay
well listen i don't know why you would
be mad about that
seems like a really weird strange very
very strange thing to be mad about
we're standing by for donald trump uh 25
minutes ago scheduled for
uh kaylee mckennany was 63 minutes late
today
just total disrespect i mean it's like
they they consider the press
to be pon scum essentially 63 minutes
late
her press briefing lasted 22 minutes
including questions
now donald trump 25 minutes late
although
it seems as though the camera people and
reporters are mostly at the ready
uh maybe one open seat here in the front
row but oh maybe not even
but it's pathetically embarrassing truly
truly embarrassing
um what else do we have going on michael
jones asks if it's worth it to donate to
the biden campaign or worth it at all i
can't tell you that that depends on your
financial situation that depends on how
respect responsibly you believe they are
deploying resources
what i can tell you is this the fact
that donald trump may have to spend
money in georgia he may have to spend
money in texas
he obviously is having to pour money
into both florida and
florida that is not good and so if we
can
keep the pressure up even in those those
purple states just to keep
forcing trump to spend money it's good
it's good you know it may not
flip the election and it's unlikely
really that that biden will win those
states like i don't think biden's
winning georgia i don't think biden's
winning texas
but if trump can't consider it a gimme
and he has to spend money that's money
he can't spend
in ohio for example or wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania et cetera
but in terms of whether you should
donate that's that's your decision
javi rodriguez said oh by the way i've
never donated to any politician and
people sometimes ask me why
i'm so politically involved number one
the influence i have through the show
is far larger than what i would have by
throwing money at a politician
and also i just want it to be
just off off the top there would not be
no
hidden agenda where i might have
unbeknownst to you contributed to a
candidate
and then i'd have to explain whether my
commentary
is affected by having don't i just don't
donate
any i've never donated a dollar to any
politician you never have to worry that
i'm
you know when i comment positively
negatively or whatever about a race
that maybe i have money in the game i
have skin in the game and that i live in
this country and i want what's best for
the country
but uh you never have to wonder whether
i might have donated to some politician
i've never donated to any politician
so they're pulling the tvs out usually
when this happens it is a signal
that there is going to be uh a
particularly
particularly propagandistic press
briefing
and um that's you know
make of that make of that what you will
and yeah it's a good question
why didn't they set the tvs up earlier
it's very weird
now 28 minutes late for the start of
this now they set up the tvs
it's pathetic uh grandmaster benjamin
feingold says always donate
always donate wow that's going to be a
conflict i think
javi rodriguez says chances of trump
indictment when he leaves office
essentially zero the here's the deal
guys
the opportunity to hold trump
accountable is to vote him out in three
months that that's the opportunity
if you have these um fantasies of trump
being walked out
in handcuffs by uh the fbi or whoever
it's you're going to be sorely
disappointed vote him out
those are the consequences period
this idea that he's going to prison or
getting indicted
the best we can hope for is trump or
organization
financial wrongdoing organization not
trump
ben diller says could the republicans be
waiting until closer to election day to
pass aid
so that short-term memory is the
prevalent factor at polls
yeah i mean i think there's no question
that donald trump would love to be able
to
take credit for a vaccine on october
10th to take credit for
some treatment whether it's plasma
plasma room desevere
remedivar however he pronounces it you
know what i'm talking about
um i certainly think so and to be clear
the chances aren't literally zero that
trump gets indicted
they are functionally zero in other
words they are
so low that there would be no action
that we would take
with the idea that he might get indicted
the
we know we can hold him accountable by
removing him in three months
this you know trump in uh trump in
handcuffs it's like
okay what else do we have
the president's ego is almost as big as
pacman's cucumber no my zucchinis are
large
my cucumbers are not yet large they uh i
started those from
seed and i have right now i have uh
nothing bigger i think i have a three
inch cuke is my biggest cuke right now
but i've pulled a bunch of 10 and 12
inch uh
uh how is this my job i've pulled a
bunch of foot long zooks
bunch of very large zooks i made a uh
italian granny
um zucchini soup last week
let's see here um chris stultz
careful with sam davidson why davidson
he sent many libertarian debate lords to
early graves oh my god
that's ugly danny thompson says whoa
where did that go where did danny's
message go
sometimes when a bunch of super chats
come in at once it scrolls
then he says would you consider doing an
almost illegal membership price of 15
for your 15-year anniversary of the show
danny you're thinking now you're
thinking danny
okay i mentioned a couple weeks ago that
uh or i guess yesterday feels like a
couple weeks ago
i mentioned that this month is the
15-year anniversary of the david pakman
show when we started
i was in mere kindergarten and now we it
is the 15-year anniversary of the show
towards the end of the month we are
going to have a membership special
that if the soviet union had not fallen
apart
it would likely fall because of this
membership special
that's how whacked this membership
special is and in fact
my employees have staged an intervention
to try to stop me from doing this
membership special
to celebrate 15 years of the david
pakman show
and they're not going to they're not
going to be able to stop me okay so
danny
beautiful question and more about that
15 for 15 whoa what's going on here
uh-oh we've got uh i'm getting
massive thunderstorm warnings i hope
that i don't lose power during this
that would not be good i actually think
i just heard a huge branch fall
so things things could get ugly guys
i'll do what i can
joseph you says you were stressing me
out for a minute there david
oh i don't know why rainer mendes says
david did you see the explosion in
lebanon yes
i at this point there's nothing more i
can add so by tomorrow's podcast i will
have researched it for
you and i will have some broader
commentary about it
thanks to zingerlicious for the twitch
prime sub
if it fits has subscribed mad mac 2k17
welcome r gray and whip viper
dirt 11 has subscribed
uh a lot happening on twitch right now a
lot a lot happening
you guys may have seen yesterday that
there was
uh speaking of a shot across the bow
grand master hikaru nakamura
stated yesterday unequivocally and with
perfect clarity
that he prefers the david pakman show to
the political commentary of stephen
kenneth destiny banel ii
okay i don't want this to cause a rift
between stephen and i but i can
uh show you that clip because it is
some people were very very offended by
this which was said let me quickly get
to it because it seems we're very close
to donald trump listen to this
category yes steve stephen kenneth
destiny benell the second would be an
interesting player in the tournament
uh yeah i mean you i like i feel like
your
politics and the way you explain things
is a little bit better honestly like
really oh my god clip that jeez holy
[ __ ] we've got to clip that
thing that's shocking so that was a
really big moment i think for the uh
there's the progressive twitch community
which
i think is like not that many people and
progressive political streamers i mean
there's lots of progressives on twitch
and then there's the chess community and
that was a beautiful then if you imagine
a venn diagram that was a
beautiful um sort of intersection
of the progressive and chess community
and it was
it was serious it was a really big
moment a lot of people contacted me to
congratulate me for that
okay kurt wells says why do you think
it's taken this long for reporters to
take trump to task and the fashion axios
did
do you think others just weren't as
effective there's just so here's what
you have to understand
in the united states the fear of a
journalist losing access to people in
positions of power
creates sort of a constant status quo
of softball interviews and so when chris
wallace says to trump
hey you know i took that cognitive test
it wasn't that hard and people go oh
oh my god hardball no when everybody
else is playing softball
playing the normal game of journalism
seems like you are playing hardball in
other countries trump arguably never
would have made it to the presidency
because the serious interviews he would
have gotten early on would have
completely destroyed him so
we had a journalist who did an interview
and when the person
in power said something that made no
sense
like the manuals and books say not to
test very much
and jonathan swann goes what manuals
what are you talking about what books
um it looks like he's doing something
amazing he's just doing his job
and i think that that's a uh you know
let's not miss the forest for the trees
or allow the overton window on what
counts as journalism to be moved
chris n says please take this money and
buy 1 100
of a tesla share yeah i don't know where
tesla
stock is right now full disclosure as
many of you know i've owned
tesla stock for a long time where is
tesla stock right now
right around 1500 bucks okay yeah that's
that's high
that's high for sure i bought in
february of 2015
so i don't know exactly what the price
was then i think it was around 200 bucks
yeah looks like it um i'm just holding
i i'm a buy and hold sort of guy
let's see bay photo says the guy
concerned about a
rigged election wants to rig the
election classic yeah that's essentially
it
ashtray vlogs says here's for hope
congrats on the growth man thank you
juggalo trey hey david pakman
will you ever come on my unnamed weekly
podcast you know if i don't even know
the name of it it's going to be hard for
me to appear
adam de spain says is it possible the
rnc convention nominates someone other
than trump
no absolutely not michael sancevero
says my fear is when voted out what will
he do in his last two months in office
it's not just what will he do it's what
will his followers do
what will the gun people do if biden
wins
by a small margin and trump claims it
was rigged that's really
the scary thing mandings
says how do you think makanani would
fare
in an axios interview she would be
brutalized
it would be brutal ian jones says senate
was holding hearing
calling antifa organized foreign
terrorism they're out of their minds
ty strong asked do you think the
republicans holding up relief for
americans is just the next
cash property and land grab for the
wealthy well the wealthy have done very
well during the virus and there's a few
different ways that that's been the case
and you can check out my youtube clip
i forget the name of it but it's
something like a lot of money is being
made with coronavirus including no bid
sweetheart contracts to companies that
didn't even exist eight months ago from
the trump administration
um there's a whole bunch of ways in
which a lot of money
a lot of money has been made due to
coronavirus
okay here we go here is donald trump
let's uh
see what we got today it's gonna be
brutal i hope everybody's strapped in
thank you very much
somber trump begin by sending america's
deepest sympathies
to the people of lebanon where reports
indicate that
many many people were killed
hundreds more were very badly wounded in
a large explosion in beirut
our prayers go out to all the victims
and their families the united states
stands
ready to assist lebanon we have a very
good relationship
with the people of lebanon and we will
be there to help
it looks like a terrible attack
i also want to provide the latest on
tropical storm
east side approximately 600 000
are without power along the east coast
was it named that way just so trump
couldn't say it
talk to restore service as quickly as
possible i spoke to governor cooper i
spoke to
governor desantis and i spoke to
all of the people at fema and they're
working very hard
by the way did trump call it an attack
in beirut like do we know that or did he
just reveal something that he was
briefed on
uh confidentially and he wasn't supposed
to say that
and very very high winds fema is
responding to states that have requested
the assistance we have a list of those
states we can give them to you in a
little while and
my administration is monitoring the
situation very closely
we have uh the military on guard but we
have
fema is there in all cases corps of
engineer is ready
if needed the army corps of engineers
very talented people
i urge everyone in the storm's path to
remain alert
and to follow the guidance of your state
and local authorities
i now want to update you on the
path forward having to do with the china
virus before i do that i want to
give you some numbers which are rather
spectacular that just came out
the manufacturing index of the institute
for
supply management that's ism most of you
know it by ism
increased for the third month in a row
rising nearly two points in july to 54.2
that was fantastic the highest reading
since
march of 2019 this
is remarkable considering the survey was
conducted throughout july and
showed significant improvement despite
the southwest
in particular virus hot spots the ism
measures
and it's a very strong measure of new
orders rose five points in july to 61.5
and its highest reading that would be
since september
of 2018 that's a big number
since the april low new orders are up
over 34 points
which is the largest increase in the
history of the ism dating back all the
way to 1948
so as if he understands math just
since 1948
similarly the ism's measure of
production is up 35 points from its
april low
to a reading of 62.1 which is the
largest three-month gain
in over 70 years at some
some number these were
somewhat surprising but i've been saying
we're doing
well and those numbers are really
spectacular automobile sales likewise
are a key factor in the resurgence of
manufacturing since
the march low of 8.8 million units
with sales and all i'm glad trump knows
the difference between numbers and
letters that's something
stunningly it's 65 percent increase
since then to 14.5 million units which
is a
a massive number
the great strength and great news
is really for states like in particular
michigan and ohio south carolina
pennsylvania very good interesting he's
mentioning three of those four states
which are crucial states if he's going
to get re-elected
record-setting numbers the strength in
new car sales is also evident in the
used-car market where
soaring demand literally soaring demand
is putting upward pressure on
the used car prices this is a
leading indicator of the motor vehicle
industry
the need to restock depleted shelves
will further galvanize the factory
sector and we think very substantially
based on the numbers
we're very very happy with these numbers
and i think most people are
anywhere from surprise to shocked by
these numbers
in a very positive way economy-wide
inventories crashed
at a near 320 billion dollar
annualized rate last quarter the crash
in that case means a good
thing not a bad thing that's the largest
drop ever on record ever it's a good
crash
homebuilder sentiment likewise is
soaring as our home
sale sentiment is now higher than last
year in new homes recently made a
13-year high so we have a 13 year high
in
new home new home construction new
business applications are very strong
that just came out
the widely followed atlanta what does
that even mean a new business
application you don't really
like is he saying just businesses
business entities are being registered
is that ein registrations
with any one of these dumb comments it's
like what do you what do you mean
business registrations
applications it doesn't make any sense
size growth in the current quarter
so 20 in the current quarter will take
that
all day long let's see if that's right
that's a projection
so we'll see if that's right the atlanta
fed very respected
the virus
back to that we are continuing to
monitor
and monitor particular hot spots across
the south
southwest and the west and we're seeing
indications that our strong mitigation
efforts are working
very well actually especially to protect
those who are
most at risk which has really been our
primary focus
for ever since we've gotten to
understand this
horrible horrible plague that's been
unleashed in our country by china
as of yesterday cases are declining
in 70 percent of the jurisdictions
compared to 36 percent
last monday that's a big big
number so what counts as a jurisdiction
number two florida stopped testing last
week because of the hurricane number
three he lies all the time number four
he doesn't understand math
mid-july in other states the data
suggests that the
need for continuing vigilance always is
strong even though the numbers are
getting
very good states that have a test
positivity rate between
five and ten percent and in the states
with the lowest positivity rates we also
see
slight increases in daily cases and
a couple of them we must ensure that
these states
did not become new flare-ups so we're
watching them very very closely
fortunately thanks to
substantial improvements in treatment
and the knowledge we have gained about
the disease itself the recent rise
in cases has not been accompanied by a
significant increase
in deaths fatalities nationwide are
at roughly half the level of the april
peak
so the deaths let me show you the trends
the fatalities are at half the level
one is too much one death because this
should have never happened to us it
should have been stopped it
very easily by china in wuhan
thanks to our major advances in
treatment we've seen vast improvements
in recovery rates across
all age groups compared to april
mortality rates are 85 percent lower
among
individuals aged 18 to 69
and 70 percent lower among individuals
over 70 years old
we've also made significant strides in
sheltering those at highest risk
especially
the elderly approximately 85 percent
of all current cases are individuals
under the age of 65.
just getting some very accurate numbers
on this
and these are people who are generally
at a much lower risk of
complications since the pandemic began
nearly half of all fatalities have been
at nursing homes or assisted
living centers that's an incredible
statistic when you hear that number
this data underscores that the best path
forward
is an aggressive strategy focused on
protecting americans at highest risk
as we race toward the development of a
vaccine
we must continue to take extraordinary
precautions to shield the elderly
and we're doing that we're doing that at
a level that we've never even
dreamt possible both shielding the
elderly at a level we never dreamed we
could shield the elderly that's the
assertion
especially the elderly with the
underlining whether it's heart
or diabetes they seem to be the two most
predominant conditions that cause
tremendous problems
while allowing those at lowest risk to
carefully return
to work and to school
where embers flare up we must engage
immediately and that's what we're doing
this is the science-based approach and
that's good with us working very hard on
that
an extended lockdown would fail to
target resources at the highest risk
populations while inflicting massive
economic pain long-lasting damage
on society and public health as a whole
so there won't be lockdowns but we watch
specific areas we're very
careless than we're putting out remember
there was never a national lockdown
there's this idea that we did this
really tough thing it was a national doc
lockdown which trump called for he never
called for it different states at
different times had different
degrees of lockdown trump then just
talked about opening opening opening and
now he says we're not going back to that
full lockdown which the country never
actually did
medicine as we discussed the last time
as
and as i said uh numerous times during
this day it's an incredible thing that's
happening a central part of our effort
to protect the elderly is to greatly
expand access to telehealth
so seniors can be treated from the
safety of their homes
and that's what's happening the number
of medicare beneficiaries using
telehealth increased from roughly
14 000 a week to nearly 1.7 million so
from 14
000 to 1.7 million per week in total
10 million medicare beneficiaries of
excess telehealth services since the
pandemic began that's a tremendous thing
that's happened with telehealth
as we shelter those at high risk we are
also pouring every resource
at our disposal into the development of
therapies and vaccines plasma
two vaccine candidates are currently in
the final stage of clinical trials
with several more vaccine candidates
entering phase three
in the coming weeks and you've read and
seen what's happened today today's news
was very exciting
through operation warp speed we're also
mass producing all of the most promising
vaccine candidates and we're determined
to have a vaccine
very quickly we think we're going to
have something very soon
we have great companies these are the
among the greatest companies in the
world
but right now they don't like me so much
because i'm forcing them to drop
drug prices prescription drug prices he
said it wouldn't even happen until 2021
at which point he might not even be
president all right we're having a
tremendous you'll see a tremendous drop
in price we're using favorite nations
we're using the rebates we're using
everything so long i've heard about he's
going to send you coupons you can clip
you know
they call them the middlemen and uh
they are very wealthy nobody even knows
who they are
but they're very wealthy people and
we're doing the rebates
is wealthy bad because trump ran on
being wealthy is the reason why you
should vote for him
much less money than the united states
is allowed to under
a very bad system i don't call it
archaic i call it bad
because it's meant really for drug
companies to get higher prices what is
he talking about
uh under under the system of matching
that we have
if germany has a pill for ten cents and
ours is two dollars
we're allowed to say we want favorite
nations and we want the pill for the
same the same as the lowest country in
the world if they sell to one country
lower than
anybody else that's the price we're
going to get drug companies aren't too
happy about that big pharma
we've also dramatically accelerated the
availability of plasma therapies
steroid treatments antivirals and other
therapies to treat the illness
today the nih we're very exciting
announced that
they're beginning the trial of two new
antibody treatments which will
take place in 40 cities across the
country we're going to
move very quickly results look very good
already incredible results more than
230 clinical trials so potential
treatments are underway and we've
secured 500 000 courses of treatment
for rem deservier of remdessevier
we're really doing a job with it and
it's helping a lot of people that's why
you see
the fatalities and mortality numbers
looking very good relatively speaking
that is but that's for american
hospitals through the month of september
so we have room desevere
at a very high level for hospitals
through the month of september that's
big news
right the united states also is far and
away the most robust testing capacity in
the world
testing has been incredible what we've
been able to do nobody's even close
since march 12th we've increased daily
testing by
32 000 how's that 32 000
percent somebody would say that must be
a typo no it's not we just had no tests
when when you know you start with zero
tests you can get some pretty good
growth rates
nationwide averaging over 820
000 tests per day and nearly 5 million
tests per week and now that we're
understanding
the virus we're understanding very much
what we're doing
with respect to who it affects who it's
uh
destroying and who gets away with it
like young people very young people
uh we'll be having some interesting
statements having to do with testing and
focus testing i call it focus today it's
going to make
interesting statements by comparison
mexico so we're doing
numbers that are incredible but by
comparison
uh mexico as you know the president was
here is a great guy but their
their numbers are much different they do
about one million tests france has done
2.9 million tests canada is around the
form meaningless
meaningless australia's around the 4
million mark the united states is
testing more people in a single week
than
in many cases large segments or large
well-known countries all put together
what counts as a well-known
country to trump testing and the quality
of the testing also
and now we're doing testing where you
can have results in five minutes
seven minutes and 15 minutes as opposed
to waiting to come back from labs for
you to come back from still even here in
massachusetts where things are pretty
good you have to wait five to seven days
for results
testing sites in baton rouge new orleans
phoenix miami jacksonville florida
mcallen texas bakersfield california and
this week we're opening new
surge sites in houston texas atlanta
to date more than 130 000 tests have
been conducted at these sites
last week the fda also authorized the
first two tests that display
an estimated quantity of antibodies
present in the individual's blood which
is a big deal allowing us to learn more
about
the immune response fema and hhs has
worked with the private sector to
deliver
more than we have new numbers more than
200 million n95 masks
855 million surgical masks gowns
36 million goggles and face shields
364 million gowns and coveralls
billion gloves billion can you believe
that billion gloves
and we distribute that to the governors
different states and
when we get on the phone with them
they're very happy that i can tell you
right no complaints from any of them
they're very very happy
what they say to you separately maybe
will change for political reasons but
they are very happy with
the job we've done in our national
stockpile we've tripled the number of
n95 masks on hand to more than 40
million
triple the number of gowns to 15 million
and quadruple the number of ventilators
to nearly 70
000 these numbers are growing every day
and we're now making
thousands of ventilators many thousands
of ventilators a month and
we're getting them to other countries
who are desperately in need of
ventilators they're very hard to produce
and very complicated machines so we're
we're fully stocked here and we've made
sure that every state is fully stocked
but we're getting them to a lot of
countries that need help
we'll continue to work with the
governors and local authorities to help
them
ensure significant hospital capacity
protective equipment supplies and
medicine
i'm more confident than ever that we
will get a vaccine very soon and we will
defeat the virus and very low energy i
want to thank you all for being here
we'll take a few questions
uh yeah please i wanted to ask you about
kodak you had a big announcement the
other day about getting kodak into the
pharmaceutical business but the sec is
now
investigating what happened can you say
a word or two whether you think that
there might have been some kind of a
problem
uh in terms of how those arrangements
were made is there any grounds
for concern from your perspective
well i don't know i wasn't involved in
the deal the concept of the deal is good
but i'll let you know we'll we'll do
a little study on that he's going to see
whether there was an entire insider
training
and let you know but i wasn't involved
in it
it's a big deal it's a way of bringing
back a great area too in addition to
pharmaceuticals kodak has been a great
name but obviously
pretty much in a different business and
so we'll see what that's all about but
we'll we'll let you know very quickly
yeah please um i just want to follow up
before i ask the coronavirus
question on lebanon you call this an
attack there we go
uh are you confident that this was an
attack and not an accident
well it would seem like it based on the
explosion i've met with
some of our great generals and they just
seemed to feel that it was this was not
that's news it's not clear whether he
was supposed to be saying that uh
manufacturing
uh explosion type of event this was a
uh seems to be according to them they
would know better than i would but they
seem to think it was a
attack it was a bomb of some kind yes
interesting
um and on coronavirus you've talked a
lot about when you talk about the
mortality rate
the deaths as a proportion of cases
which i understand that is
significant when you look at how deadly
the virus is or how good a country does
at keeping people alive who get infected
but when you're talking about the scope
of this virus when you look at the
percentage of the population that's died
there's only three countries that have
more deaths than the us
so how do you explain that that why the
percentage of the population has died
is so much higher in the u.s we're going
to talk about it actually the numbers
are lower than others i'll get back to
you on that but we proportionately are
lower than almost
all countries we're at the bottom of the
list not true
uh relative to cases also we're at the
bottom of the list which he's
saying so i've been saying this for
months jonathan swann finally asks about
it in the axios interview
now everybody all of a sudden is like
why is he keep talking about case
fatality
uh you know cronovirus resource center
is on their website it says the most
affected countries
when you look at deaths for 100 000
people the population so how many people
the population have died
right the uk peru chile and then the u.s
um you know canada has eight thousand
nine thousand deaths obviously they're
smaller than us but
that's only six percent population
you know that's six percent of our total
cases so why
aren't he's he doesn't understand these
numbers we're based on the new york had
a very tough time as you know new york
new jersey that area
and when you take them out uh just as an
example take a look at florida relative
to new york
that's not to say uh anything wrong with
new york it's just a very tough place
people are close together it's crowded
it's uh if people keep hammering on
him on this he actually may crack among
the lowest and
even with it in i will get back to you
but we have among the lowest numbers
they've done a fantastic job
yes mr president i would like to ask a
question about the election but
one thing on unemployment first are you
considering
taking executive action to extend or
rather reinstate the unemployment
benefits that expired last week if
congress can't get a deal by the end of
the week
and as a general point what rate then
would you want in there
a percentage or flat rate we are looking
at it we're also looking at
uh various other things that i'm allowed
to do under the system
and uh such as first of all notice this
is the low somber voice he uses
sometimes
anytime you ask him to give you the
percentages or numbers he's not he just
doesn't know he's not going to do it
solving the problems of some of the
democrat-run states and cities that have
uh suffered greatly through
bad management i mean really bad
management so that seems to be where
they're looking for a trillion dollars
to help out with cities that are run by
democrats
in some cases radical left democrats
that have not done a good job i
appreciate today the wall street journal
said very good things that
we did a great job in portland by having
our
people go in homeland security chad
wolfe and folks we went into uh
portland and we've done a great job and
they had that in an editorial that we
that we really won that situation but we
want the whole we
didn't lose the security the courthouse
was going to be
burned down or not everything's winning
and losing to this guy
danger we went in we took care of it and
we appreciated what the wall street
journal said
as far as the various things that i may
or may not sign
uh i may not have to sign i mean
progress is being
made as you know very well in the hill
we'll see what happens
but i have the right including the
payroll tax suspension
we may do some things we want to take
care of the eviction problem people
are being evicted very unfairly it's not
their fault it's china's fault it's not
their fault
and people are being evicted and we can
do that with an executive order so if we
don't get
and we want to do it relatively quickly
i mean even from the standpoint of
covid uh people at the standpoint then
they go into shelters and there's
thousands of people in the shelters and
this is not a time
you never want to be in a shelter but
this is not a time to be in a shelter
with a covet
they catch it they get it and it's no
good
so i may have to do something on
evictions too because the democrats
amazingly don't want to do it we offered
them short-term deals and
we offered them lots remember democrats
wanted to do something on it two months
ago and this guy just sat on it and said
we may not have to things may be great
it's by democrats
okay and if i put on the election sir
can i present trump
on the uh the sale of tick tock you're
basically arguing that the u.s
government is going to collect
a cut from a transaction including two
companies
in which it doesn't hold a stake in
that's unprecedented that's never
happened in u.s history before and the
administration has offered very little
explanation about
how that's going to work take your
statement out and
provide specifics about you say that's
impressive did you actually use that
term
i said it's unprecedented well it's
almost the same thing
not quite i like it he thought someone
was praising him for a second
not twice close so tick tick
tick tock is very successful it does i
want tic tacs banned i'm done with tic
tacs
riveted by it i mean i have many friends
when they saw that announcement they're
calling
i think their kids love it they don't
because they don't get to see their kids
anymore but they are it's it's an
amazing
thing whatever it may be and he doesn't
whatever it is
microsoft and frankly others if they
want to whatever it is it's great but
we're banning it and taking a cut
tick-tock whether it's the 30 in the
united states or the whole company
i say it's okay but if you do that
we're really making it possible because
we're letting you
operate here so the united states
treasury would have to benefit also
not just the not just the sellers and i
said inform
very simple i mean we have we have all
the cards because without us you can't
come into the united states it's like
guys
this sounds like communism the tenant's
business
needs a rent it needs a lease and
so what i said to them is whatever
the price is a very big proportion of
that price would have to go to the
treasury of the united states
what do bookies call it is this a vig
what's the appropriate term guys squeak
with me very much yeah please anybody
thank you thank you so that deal may or
may not happen we've given them until
september 15th or so
and we'll see if we can have it and if
there can be great security
meaning the obvious security microsoft
would be a company that would be good in
that respect
or approved in that respect at many
levels including working with
the department of defense and you know
they're very high level approvals so
microsoft buys it
it can continue and trump takes a slice
i guess if you or the
anyone in administration reached out to
other companies aside from microsoft
to see if they're interested we've had
other companies call
us microsoft called me directly
and we've had other companies call i
don't know where they are it sounds like
microsoft is along the way of doing
something
tax uh i don't blame them it'd be you
know it's a great company it's really a
great company but
we cannot take the security risks of any
of those companies
including huawei which as you know we
put a halt to
but we can't take the security risk i
think our attitude on china has changed
greatly since the
china virus hit us i think it changed
greatly it hit the world and it
shouldn't have
they should have been able to stop it so
uh
we feel differently i just don't know
when you lose when you lose
so many thousands of people and you know
ultimately it'll be millions of people
around the world
uh it's a terrible thing that happened
to oh now he's actually saying the
global death toll will be in the
millions that's interesting
yes please president i have two quick
questions one on the buyer someone
policing on
the virus you said recently that there
can be too much testing
can you explain what the downside would
be from testing
too many americans for the virus and why
you haven't provided
a date by which all americans might have
the same kind of testing that we have
here at the white house
well we do more testing than anybody in
the world as i explained and i don't
mean just a little bit if you look at
india they're
at about 11 million and we're at 61
million per capita
and there comes a point when you just
you you want to focus your testing in a
different way
and we'll be announcing some what we've
done is incredible with the testing not
only the testing
not only the number of tests but also
very importantly the quality of the test
and the machinery itself to do the
testing
nobody thought it would be possible to
get a 5 minute and a 15 minute result
that's a very accurate result and we do
with abbott abbott laboratories has done
a great job many of these companies have
done an incredible job
so we're looking at that very strongly
and we're looking at
just remember guys just because trump's
repeating the same thing and you
probably don't need to hear it again
now actually test comparing our testing
per capita to other countries while
still relevant
if a country has dealt with the virus
they don't have people to test because
nobody has it or very few people has
have it so at this point like early was
the time to be
killing everybody in test per capita now
we have to keep testing a lot because we
still have so many cases other countries
don't
it's even believable that we're able to
test so much
61 million versus you know right
countries it's
we are only able to do that because we
have so many cases if somebody's feeling
badly they're symptomatic
that's when they test and that's a big
difference with us we go around
and looking because if we find we find
spots we find hot spots
one problem is from the standpoint of
guys we're five months in you know it's
like if he still doesn't get this
it's it's the ship has sailed the ship
has sunk
i called it the other day and a
statement i said it's called media gold
you know for the media it's gold but the
truth is it's
uh we've done an incredible job in
testing nobody in the world has done the
job other leaders have told me the same
thing they can't believe we're able to
do it
and and we will continue but we want to
really be able to test very specific but
i just saw a super chat from philip
defranco and he just followed me on
twitter i think that may be the real uh
the real philly d that that's wild uh
first of all
uh what you tweeted out earlier today in
regards to florina
uh and your comfortableness as it
relates to male and balance for florida
why does that apply to florida and it
doesn't apply to mail and balloting
across the country so florida's got a
great republican governor
and it had a great republican governor
wow ron desantis
rick scott two great governors and over
a long period of time
they've been able to get the absentee
ballots
done extremely professionally florida's
different from other states
i mean in nevada where you have a
governor he said let's just send out
different in a lot of bad ways i hate to
say
not be prepared i haven't spoken to the
post office about it but i don't know
how they could possibly be prepared
florida has been working on this for
years and they have a very good system
of what trump means is he votes in
florida and he doesn't want to be called
out for it and he votes by mail
so in the case of florida there aren't
too many people that would qualify
they're so well run florida is a very
well run state low taxes
know everything they've done a great job
really a great job and the two governors
between the both of them they've really
got a great system of absentee ballots
and
uh even the even in the case of mail-in
ballots
uh the postal services are built up
there you know it takes a long time
when you look at the carolyn maloney
election i think they and i'll give you
the story i think you have to do that
election over that election is no good
you have to take a look in new york they
have thousands
of ballots they don't know what happened
to them is there fraud is there it's a
disaster that's only for a
relatively small number of ballots
but i think they have to do the election
in new york over the times wrote a big
story about it
yesterday front page story it's a
disaster it's a mess
and they have to do that i think they
have to do that election over nobody can
know what the election result is
so in the case of florida they've done a
great job florida's good they've had
tremendous success with it
but they've been doing this over many
years and they've made it really
terrific sofa
there are states that are entirely vote
by mail that have been doing it for
years the idea that
that florida run by intellectual smurf
ron desantis is the picture that we
should all be fine
it's unbelievable they're going to be
voting in a matter of weeks and
you can't do that i can't imagine the
post office could do it all of a sudden
they're supposed to be dealing in
millions of ballots
but florida's done a great job and we
have total confidence that if you mail
in your ballot in florida it's going to
matter
thank you thank you thank you what about
in other states
did you encourage those gingerly oh
he's looking even more ginger in his
walking than we've seen him many times
before what a [ __ ] show right guys
i mean just uh the rantings of a
confused
madman and this was the tweet that was
being referred to
about whoa sam cedar out of nowhere this
was the tweet that was being referred to
let's see if i can zoom it for us a
little bit
and a tweet that it makes as little
sense as it appears to make
okay it's it's as ridiculous
whether you call it vote by mail or
absentee implies it's the same thing
which it is but he's been saying that
they're two different things
all along and i mean it's like at this
point do we even need to analyze these
things in this detail it's like when
trump talks about
case fatality rate versus death per
capita of course he doesn't get it and
if he got it
he would just lie so like what what are
we really doing is this really what
american politics has come to it this
it's exhausting that's exactly right
people who are saying
they're tired that's exactly right
listen um
shots have been fired across the bow by
sam cedar
he made some very very ugly statements
claiming that
some of our now 914
000 subscribers are fake that they're
bots so tomorrow i'm going to be
responding to this
and we will be kicking up an extremely
extensive completely fake
uh battle against sam cedar but the part
that's very real is we're trying to get
to a million subscribers by election day
so before you head out all 15 000 of you
who are watching on youtube
please hit that subscribe button it's a
free button
i'm selling you nothing here it's just a
free button
we can't allow these insults from samuel
cedar
to take down the integrity of this
channel
thanks for joining me today i'll be back
tomorrow we've got a new show
there will probably be streams tomorrow
night on twitch only i'll be joined
or i will be joining alex botez who will
be teaching me
more about how i might avoid
embarrassment in the upcoming pog champs
two chess tournament on chess.com
that'll be tomorrow night i believe 6 45
pm eastern 3 45 pm pacific
we'll see you then
you